[Music]
oh
hey
yeah we got
we can put her down
[Music]
but he said nothing's gonna happen
because i don't know what's going on
okay we just gotta figure out what's
going on so just have a seat he said
that they're gonna do like like just let
me go after they're done all right
that's my sister i'm just trying to
figure out should be all right okay
there's just a lot of guns in the car we
gotta figure out what's going on okay
okay if you mind kicking your feet in
i'll roll down the window
my sister
you're not
you're not like an and you're missing
person or anything no okay
which one is your sister me how
how long she got to stay in here
we just have to figure out there's a lot
of guns in that car
like a lot of guns and if you don't mind
me asking like why did y'all have to
like look in the car or you just y'all
just did it
what's that i don't i don't know why
they what made you search the cars i
don't know
i don't know if you can see my car is
way back here right so i was the last
one
i don't know i don't know if someone
called and said that there were people
with guns in the car i don't know
but i don't know y'all
oh
hey
i think there's like five or six guns in
the car i think we're trying to leave
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
over here
what's your best number
[Applause]
oh
you only heard
[Applause]
that's right but i was here before you
were involved tell me or somebody
my name was
oh
[Applause]
questions
so why did y'all take the car
right there why did they check the car i
don't have to tell you anything
you don't have probable cars you all
pulled up popped out and walked into a
car
what about that girl that got shot
about it the one in cleveland
he's one of the chicken chasers
did you know that did you know that did
you know that if you're gonna ask me a
question that's her question did you
know it was guns in the car or again
i showed up later
so you know with guns in the car or i
thought
detectives
[Music]
wait
[Applause]
bro
today though
because you guys don't say anything
[Applause]
spread
this female people yeah
okay
uh we're finding out right now okay dear
so it'll be a minute
get back
[Applause]
okay everybody go to techway checkpoint
yeah
your sister grabbed it
i can't see it
you're good you're good you're good
attack away all right
we got everybody out there
go back out to uh
is
so one of the officers that made the
initial stop just wants to talk to you
about the people in the car
hey dear uh go ahead step on when i talk
to you
so you're not being charged with
anything okay okay but uh we're just
gonna get you home or something
what's your address like where your
guardian live with your mom or then you
gotta work there
is what's your assistant
where
[Applause]
oh
that's what i was looking for nevermind
i was gonna say we're gonna take the
females home okay i don't know whose
cuffs these
were better
[Applause]
it's a matter of time before i mean
listen i'm going to jail to lose your
following
people
out the wrong folk
people out to shoot them if you're next
to them you might get shot yourself
right are you are you staying on menson
or
okay your friend is in the back of our
car we're just gonna give you guys a
ride back home okay thank you so much
all right thank you so please
right there thank you you're welcome
have a nice night
[Applause]
now